L
NIGHT FROM THE STATE OF FLORIDA,
INCLUDING ON THIS SHOW.
BUT FIRST A STEP BACK.
SO WHEN SOMETHING THIS AWFUL
HAPPENS, SOMETHING THAT AFFECTS
THE LIVES OF MILLIONS OF YOUR
FELLOW AMERICANS, DECENT PEOPLE
STEP BACK FOR A MOMENT.
IT'S A MOMENT THAT DEMANDS
REVERENCE AND SILENCE TO
CONSIDER WHAT WE'VE JUST SEEN.
THEN THE PRACTICAL QUESTIONS.
PEOPLE ARE SUFFERING.
HOW ARE THEY SUFFERING?
THEY DON'T HAVE POWER OR
COMMUNICATIONS.
HOW MANY HOMES WERE DESTROYED?
YOU ASK QUESTIONS LIKE THIS,
ASSESS WHAT THIS MEANS AND THE
HUMAN COST OF IT.
THE ONE THING YOU DON'T DO IS
IMMEDIATELY JUMP FORWARD TO
SCORE A CHEAP AND SHE'SY
POLITICAL POINT FROM IT.
THAT USED TO BE OBVIOUS.
BUT FOR THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS
IT'S BEEN CLEAR IT'S NO LONGER
OBVIOUS.
AT LEAST TO ONE POLITICAL PARTY.
YOU SAW THIS HAPPEN AFTER THE
FOREST FIRES IN CALIFORNIA TWO
YEARS AGO.
IT HAPPENED AFTER TORNADOES
KILLED PEOPLE IN THE MIDWEST
LAST YEAR.
IT'S HAPPENING AGAIN NOW.
IMMEDIATELY ON CABLE TELEVISION,
ON THE FLOOR OF THE LEGISLATIVE
BODIES ACROSS THIS COUNTRY,
SELF-DESCRIBED EXPERTS ARE
DEMANDING THAT YOU ACCEPT
RESPONSIBILITY FOR WHATEVER
NATURAL DISASTER HAS JUST
OCCURRED.
IT'S YOUR FAULT, INCLUDING FOR
HURRICANE IAN.
YOU DID THIS, BECAUSE YOU DIDN'T
SUPPORT GIVING JOE BIDEN
TRILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO FIGHT
CLIMATE CHANGE.
SO YOU CAUSED IT.
WATCH.
>> DECADES AGO IT USED TO BE ONE
OR TWO A SEASON WOULD HAPPEN.
NOW WITH CLIMATE CHANGE, THE
EXTREME WARM WATERS, IT'S
HAPPENING ALL THE TIME.
>> THIS STORM IN A WAY IS KIND
OF BAD NEWS FOR THE PEOPLE STILL
TRYING TO DENY CLIMATE CHANGE IS
A FACTOR.
>> FLORIDA REPUBLICANS DENY
CLIMATE CHANGE AS A MONSTER
STORM BARRELS TOWARD THE COAST.
>> THIS WILL BE A FIRST-TIME
TEST FOR HOW YOU ADAPT TO THESE
NEW STRONGER STORMS ON A WARMER
PLANET AS A RESULT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
>> THE THREAT EXACERBATED, OF
COURSE, BY CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> CHARLESTON, LIKE MIAMI, GETS
WATER THAT COMES UP ON A GOOD
SUNNY DAY.
THAT'S CLIMATE CHANGE, BECAUSE
WATER LEVELS ARE RISING.
>> OUR EARTH IS GETTING WARMER.
THERE IS JUST NO DOUBT, I THINK,
LEFT THAT IT IS FEEDING THESE
BEASTS.
>> Jesse: IMAGINE TAKING A
SCIENCE LECTURE FROM SOMEONE AS
STUPID AS STEPHANIE RULE.
ON THAT LEVEL, IT'S RIDICULOUS.
IT'S ALSO, AS WE JUST SUGGESTED,
UNSEEMLY AND ANTIHUMAN.
OF COURSE PEOPLE ARE DYING, SO
WAIT JUST A MOMENT BEFORE
PUTTING FORWARD YOUR DEMANDS FOR
MORE POLITICAL POWER.
IT'S ALSO FACTUALLY UNTRUE.
YOU JUST HEARD ONE HAIR HAT SAY
IT'S HAPPENING ALL THE TIME.
YOU HEAR THIS ALL THE TIME.
IT'S A WAY OF TERRIFYING YOU
INTO HANDING POLITICIANS MORE
POWER OVER YOUR LIFE.
THE FACT IS IT'S A LIE.
IT'S NOT EVEN REMOTELY TRUE.
I MEAN, IT'S NOT A CLOSE CALL.
THERE'S BEEN, AS A FACTUAL
MATTER, NO INCREASE IN HURRICANE
FREQUENCY IN THE CONTINENTAL
UNITED STATES FROM 1900 TO 2020.
THAT'S 120 YEARS.
UNDER THE CIRCUMSTANCES BEEN
REPORTED.
WE HAVE THE DATA.
THEY'RE ON YOUR SCREEN RIGHT
NOW.
IN THAT CASE, AS MICHAEL
SHELLENBERGER HAS POINTED OUT,
SOMEONE WHO HAS LOOKED AT THE
NUMBERS, THE NUMBER OF
LANDFALLING HURRICANES HAS
DROPPED SLIGHTLY OVER THE PAST
CENTURY.
WHY?
WE'RE NOT SURE, BUT WE CAN
PROBABLY GUESS IT HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH CLIMATE OR YOUR SUV.
WE DO KNOW THAT SAME PERIOD
DEATHS HAVE DROPPED A LOT FROM
NATURAL DISASTERS.
THE DEATH TOLL IS FORECAST TO
DROP EVEN MORE AS PEOPLE RESPOND
TO THE CHANGING ENVIRONMENT.
THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE DO.
GOVERNMENT SCIENTISTS AT THE
NOAA PREDICT HURRICANES WILL
BECOME 25% LESS FREQUENT
THROUGHOUT THE 21st CENTURY.
OH.
THAT MAKES SENSE, BECAUSE THE
CURRENT ATLANTIC HURRICANE
SEASON IS THE SLOWEST ONE IN A
QUARTER CENTURY.
NONE OF THAT IS TO DOWNPLAY OR
MINIMIZE THE SAVAGESY OF
HURRICANE IAN, THE SADNESS OF
WHAT IT'S DONE TO YOUR FELLOW
AMERICANS.
IT'S HORRIBLE.
IT RACES THE QUESTION, HOW
EXACTLY ARE YOU RESPONSIBLE FOR
IT?
OF COURSE YOU'RE NOT IN ANY
SENSE.
YOU'RE NOT LIBEL FOR THAT.
YOU DIDN'T DO THAT.
YOU'RE A NORMAL PERSON, GRIEVING
FOR THE PEOPLE JUST KILLED, NOT
TRYING TO SCORE POLITICAL POINTS
ON THEIR DEATHS.
DON LAMOND HAS A BRAND-NEW
THEORY, CLAIMING STORMS THAT MAY
NOT HAVE BECOME MORE FREQUENT,
BUT, QUOTE, MORE INTENSE.
WATCH.
>> THE SCIENCE SHOWS WHAT THE
SCIENCE SHOWS.
IT'S UNDENIABLE WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
LISTEN, LET'S TALK ABOUT THE
STORM SURGE.
REALLY WHAT I WAS TRYING TO
EXPLAIN, IT'S JUST A PHENOMENON
OF THE INTENSIFYING STORMS OVER
THE YEARS, WHAT IT IS, NOT
TRYING TO SAY THAT ONE -- YOU
KNOW, THAT ONE PARTICULAR STORM
WE COULD GAUGE SOMETHING.
BUT LISTEN, YOU GET AN IDEA.
YOU'VE BEEN DOING FOR A WHILE.
I'VE BEEN COVERING THIS SINCE
I'VE BEEN IN THE BUSINESS FOR 20
YEARS, HAVE LIVED IN THE GULF
COAST.
YOU SEE THE INTENSITY OF THE
STORMS INCREASING.
THE SCIENCE DEFINITELY SHOWS
THAT.
>> Tucker: HA-HA-HA.
"SO THE INTENSITY OF THE STORMS
HAS INCREASED."
NOTICE HOW ALL TV PRESENTERS,
THE CLAIM THAT IS NEVER PROVEN.
THEY NEVER SHOW YOU HOW IT'S
TRUE.
THEY JUST ASSERT IT.
HOW DOES DON KNOW THAT?
BECAUSE OF A LONGITUDINAL STUDY
HE DID?
WELL, IN A WAY, HE LIVED ON THE
GULF COAST.
THE STORMS ARE GETTING MORE
INTENSE, BECAUSE HE'S BEEN IN
THIS BUSINESS A LONG TIME.
IS THAT TRUE?
IT'S WORTH ASSESSING, SINCE YOU
HEAR IT CONSTANTLY, AN THERE'S A
POLITICAL REASON THEY'RE TELLING
YOU THAT.
IS IT TRUE?
ARE THE STORMS GETTING MORE
EXPENSE?
IF SO, HOW MUCH MORE INTENSE ARE
THEY GETTING?
WE DID OUR LEVEL BEST.
THIS IS A NEW SHOW, TO GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF THAT.
ACCORDING TO THE LATEST MODELS
FROM THE NOAA, THE WORST CASE
SCENARIO IS THAT HURRICANES GET
5% STRONGER THIS CENTURY.
WE'RE 22 YEARS INTO THE CENTURY.
78 YEARS TO GO.
SO HURRICANES ARE 25% LESS
COMMON AND AT MOST 5% MORE
INTENSE.
DO THE MATH.
WELL, AS SCIENTISTS ROGER PELLKE
PUT IT, QUOTE, YOU SHOULD EVEN
THE MOST EXTREME CIRCUMSTANCES
OF CLIMATE CHANGE FUTURE
DISASTERS WILL LOOK A LOT LIKE
TODAY.
IT'S NOT ABOUT SCIENCE, IS IT?
ACTUALLY THERE'S NO SCIENCE
BEHIND THESE CLAIMS.
NO.
IT'S WHAT EVERYTHING IS IN THIS
INTENSELY POLITICIZED COUNTRY,
ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY TO PUSH
PEOPLE WHO DON'T VOTE THE RIGHT
WAY, COW THEM INTO SUBMISSION,
SEIZE THE MORAL HIGH GROUND, TO
PUNISH YOUR OPPONENTS.
THAT'S WHY EVEN AS BODIES ARE
STILL BEING IDENTIFIED, AND
APPARENTLY MANY HAVE NOT BEEN ON
THE STREETS OF FLORIDA, "THE
VIEW," APPARENTLY STILL ON THE
AIR, MOCKED THE PEOPLE OF
FLORIDA FOR DARING TO ASK
DISASTER RELIEF MONEY FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WATCH THIS.
>> GOVERNOR DESANTIS SAYS IT'S
ALL HANDS ON DECK TO PREPARE FOR
WHAT'S COMING.
AND THAT INCLUDES REACHING
ACROSS THE AISLE FOR HELP.
>> ISN'T IT SOCIALISM WHEN THE
GOVERNMENT HELPS YOU?
THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> LIKE SOCIAL SECURITY AND
MEDICARE?
>> AND THE POLICE.
I MEAN, SOCIALISM.
>> Tucker: OH, SO CLEVER.
WHAT AN INCISIVE POINT.
THIS SHOW IS TOTALLY OPPOSED TO
CENSORSHIP, PULLING ANYONE OFTEN
THE AIR.
WE'RE NOT CALLING FOR THAT IN
THE CASE "THE VIEW."
WHEN THAT SHOW DOES DIE, A
WELL-DESERVED DEATH, THIS WILL
BE A BETTER COUNTRY.
THAT'S JUST TRUE.
CONSIDER WHAT YOU JUST SAW.
A HURRICANE DEVASTATES FLORIDA,
KILLS AMERICANS, AND THE
REACTION OF THE MORONS ON "THE
VIEW" IS TO LAUGH AT THEM, TO
MOCK THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUFFERING.
WHILE THEY'RE DOING THIS, THEY
CLAIM IT'S REALLY COMING FROM A
PLACE OF COMPASSION.
THEY'RE LAUGHING AT PEOPLE WHO
ARE DYING, BECAUSE THEY'RE
BETTER THAN YOU.
SEE HOW THAT WORKS.
HERE'S JOY REED.
>> IT'S A BID IRONIC NOW THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE FLORIDIANS TO
ACTUALLY POUR OVER THE BORDERS
AND GO NORTH AND GET OUT OF THE
STATE OF FLORIDA IN THE EXACT
SAME CRIES THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT ON A TROLLING
LEVEL IN THAT STATE FOR A LONG
TIME.
AND BE CAREFUL ABOUT ATTACKING
PEOPLE WHO HAVE TO MOVE TO SAVE
THEIR OWN LIVES, MOVE TO SAFETY,
BECAUSE YOU NEVER KNOW WHEN IT'S
YOUR PEOPLE THAT HAVE TO MOVE,
WHEN IT'S YOUR PEOPLE WHO HAVE
TO MIGRATE, WHEN IT'S YOUR
PEOPLE THAT HAVE TO GET ON THAT
ROAD.
>> Tucker: WE THROW A LOT OF
CABLE NEWS CLIPS ON THE AIR.
WHO CARES WHAT THE DUMMIES ON
CABLE TELEVISION SAY, BUT IT'S A
WINDOW INTO OUR BROADER
POLITICAL DEBATE.
IF YOU WIND UP IN A COUNTRY
WHERE NO ONE CAN THINK CLEARLY,
WHEN THE MOST EDUCATED HARVARD
GRADUATES LIKE JOY REED
LITERALLY CAN'T THINK IN A
LOGICAL LINEAR WAY, INCAPABLE OF
RATIONAL THOUGHT, THEN OVER TIME
YOUR WHOLE COUNTRY BECOMES
INCAPABLE OF RATIONAL THOUGHT.
PEOPLE FALL OUT OF THE HABIT OF
THINKING LIKE ADULTS.
WE'RE MOVING TOWARD THERE.
SO THESE ARE THE VERY SAME
PEOPLE, BY THE WAY, WHO CHEERED
AS ILLEGAL ALIENS WERE REMOVED
BY FORCE FROM MARTHA'S VINEYARD
AND SENT TO A MILITARY BASE.
THEY CALLED THEM TRASH, TOOK
THEM OUT WITHIN 48 HOURS WITH
THE ARMY, BUT LECTURING YOU
ABOUT COMPASSION AS THEY FLOAT
OVER A DEADLY HURRICANE.
IT'S TIME TO STOP TAKING THEM
SERIOUSLY.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT PEOPLE.
THEY CARE ABOUT ADVANCING THE
POWER OF THE POLITICAL PARTY
THEY BELONG TO.
IF YOU NEED MORE EVIDENCE OF
THAT, JOY REED WENT ON TO
EXPLAIN THAT THE HURRICANE, THE
ONE WE JUST SAW, IS NOT A MOMENT
TO STOP AND REFLECT ON THE
FLAILING JILT OF LIFE.
NO.
IT'S ANOTHER REASON TO KEEP OUR
BORDER OPEN.
WATCH.
>> THE REALITY IS THAT HUMANS,
WE'RE LITERALLY RUNNING FROM
WHAT THE CLIMATE -- FROM THE
CLIMATE CHANGE THAT WE'RE
PRETENDING ISN'T HAPPENING, BUT
WE'RE PHYSICALLY BEING MOVED
AROUND THE EARTH BECAUSE OF IT.
>> IT WILL ACTUALLY BE THE
SINGLE BIGGEST CAUSE OF
MIGRATION.
WE TALK ABOUT MIGRATION BEING
CAUSED BY CONFLICT AND WARS, IN
SYRIA AND UKRAINE.
IT'S GOING TO BE MIGRATION
BECAUSE PEOPLE CAN'T MOVE.
GENERALLY PROSPEROUS PEOPLE CAN
MOVE FIRST, BECAUSE THEY CAN
AFFORD TO, BUT WHEN THE GRAIN
STOPS GROWING, THE FIELDS START
FLOODING, THE POOR PEOPLE MOVE
TOO.
WE HAVE TO COME TO TERMS WITH
THAT'S THE MAJOR CAUSE FOR
MIGRATION, AROUND THE WORLD, AND
HERE IN AMERICA.
>> Tucker: IMAGINE WHEN THESE
PEOPLE GO HOME AT NIGHT AND LOOK
IN THE MIRROR.
"OOH, ANOTHER DAY OF
SUCCESSFULLY NOT READ TENDING TO
STUPID, FUELING TV VIEWERS INTO
WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT."
ANYONE WITH COMMON SENSE AT ALL,
THE POWERS OF OBSERVATION THAT
MOST ADULTS WOULD KNOW, THAT
WHAT THEY'RE SAYING IS
RIDICULOUS.
IAN WASN'T THE FIRST HURRICANE
IN FLORIDA.
FLORIDA GETS HURRICANES EVERY
YEAR.
MORE AMERICANS HAVE MOVED TO
FLORIDA IN THE PAST TWO YEARS
THAN ANY OTHER STATE.
CLIMATE IS NOT FORCING PEOPLE
OUT OF FLORIDA.
HOW DOES THAT WORK EXACTLY?
THEY NEVER ANSWER.
INSTEAD THEY TELL YOU THE
SOLUTION TO CLIMATE CHANGE, TO
KEEP OUR SOUTHERN BORDER OPEN.
MARTHA'S VINEYARD IS STILL OFF
LIMITS, BECAUSE THAT'S WHERE
THEIR DONORS LIVE.
THIS IS ATONEMENT FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THESE SAME PEOPLE NEVER TELL
CHINA TO OPEN ITS BORDERS.
EVEN THOUGH CHINA IS BY FAR THE
LARGEST CARBON EMITTER AND
LARGEST POLLUTER IN CONVENTIONAL
TERMS IN THE WORLD.
BUT NO ONE'S EVER IN CHINA'S
FACE ABOUT BEING AN EKNOW STATE,
A RACIST.
THEY HAVE NO MORAL OBLIGATION TO
LET PEOPLE MOVE TO BEIJING.
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT SAY CLIMATE
CHANGE IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
CHANGE IN THE WORLD, THOSE SAME
PEOPLE TELL YOU THAT CHINA IS
DOING A GREAT JOB, AND WE'RE A
CYNIC.
HERE'S OUR CLIMATE CZAR, JOHN
KERRY.
>> MY QUESTION TO YOU IS WHAT
CAN BE DONE ABOUT CHINA, THEIR
SEEMING RELUCTANCE TO
PARTICIPATE IN AFFAIRS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE LIKE OTHER
NATIONS.
>> CHINA, INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH,
CHINA HAS A PLAN.
THEY'VE PUT A PLAN IN PLACE.
WE THINK THEY COULD BE DOING
MORE.
CHINA IS GOING TO BE BUILDING
MORE ELECTRIC VEHICLES, WILL BE
PUT ON THE ROAD OVER THE NEXT
YEAR OR SO,S IN CHINA, THAN IN
ANY YOU ALL THE REST OF THE
WORLD PUT TOGETHER.
THEY ARE DEPLOYING RENEWABLE
POWER AT A RATE THAT EXCEEDS ALL
OTHER NATIONS.
THEY ARE THE LARGEST
MANUFACTURER OF RENEWABLES IN
THE WORLD.
AND SO CHINA IS MOVING.
>> Tucker: SO JOHN KERRY, WHO
REALLY IS CADAVARIOUS, IS THE
CLIMATE CZAR.
HE'S NOT ONLY SNIFFING THEIR
THRONE, HE'S DEFENDING THEM ON
CLIMATE GROUNDS?
HA-HA-HA.
IT'S NOT SUBTLE.
THEY'RE NOT EVEN TRYING.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THEY DEFINITELY DON'T CARE ABOUT
NATURAL DISASTERS.
THEY JUST WANT POWER.
THAT'S WHY THEY SUCK UP TO THE
MOST POWERFUL GUY IN THE ROOM,
CHAIRMAN XI.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
HOW DEEP IS THEIR INSINCERITY?
LAST YEAR, DURING HURRICANE
SEASON, JOE BIDEN LEVERAGED
THESE NATURAL DISASTERS AS A WAY
TO SELL HIS VACCINES.
WATCH THIS.
>> GOD FORBID A NATURAL DISASTER
STRIKES WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE READY TO BE PROTECTED
AGAINST COVID-19 AS WELL.
LET ME BE CLEAR, IF YOU'RE IN I
STATE WHERE HURRICANES OFTEN
STRIKE, LIKE FLORIDA, THE GULF
COAST, INTO TEXAS, A VITAL PART
OF PREPARING FOR HURRICANE
SEASON IS TO GET VACCINATED NOW.
>> Tucker: SURE, THE LETCH IS TS
TO GET THE VACCINE.
CAN'T WE HAVE A NATURAL DISASTER
THAT WE ACCEPT AS NATURAL?
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE CALLED
NATURAL DISASTERS.
THEY'RE PRODUCTS OF NATURE.
GOD IS IN CHARGE.
WE'RE NOT GOD.
YOU HAVE TO THINK YOU'RE NOT GOD
IN ORDER TO ADMIT THAT.
THEY THINK THEY ARE GOD, IN
CHARGE OF THE WEATHER, AND THEY
CAN'T GIVE IT A BREAK.
THEY CAN'T LET PEOPLE DIE, AND
THEIR DEATHS BE OBSERVED FOR
WHAT THEY ARE, WHICH IS A
TRAGEDY, THAT DEMANDS REVERENCE,
NOT POSTURIN